some people are calling it a delusion
saying the country is mostly blue cities
with red rural areas my attitude is I
don't know about need a national divorce
I know Michael males talks quite a bit
about it but I just know that the Divide
between cities and rural areas or red
red areas and blue areas is so different
it is completely different dimensions of
perception and reality it is people in
one state
in California with open borders with
child sex changes with Limitless
abortion that is it has drifted so far
away from where traditional Americans
are where even moderate like liberal
types are that there's no bringing that
back together so you can argue we we
can't have a national divorce and it's
like sure how does a country exist when
two states have laws that are so
Divergent and cultural views are so
Divergent they're ready to start
shooting each other